مادلين اليوم
قديه بمصر وانت عشتي في مصر هي بوابه فعلا
للنجوميه خصوصا في عالم التمثيل امام زحمه
الاعمال الدراميه الكثيره في عالمنا اليوم
العربي
ليكي انا واقعيه ورح اقول الحقيقه في
دراما عظيمه عم تطلع علينا اللي هي
الدراما اللبنانيه وفيها خليجي وفيها
احيانا سوري في احيانا مصري وفي دراما
تاني عم تنعمل تاريخيه كانت سابقا واصبحت
دراما هلا بس السوريه لكن طبعا الظروف
الامنيه شوي اخرتها وفي دراما الخليجيه
دراما شابه لكن شابه قويه جدا لكن رغم كل
هذه الدراما المتواجده على الساحه الفنيه
وبدون ملعقه التخرج
من مصر يعني مصر مثل ما تقولي بتعطيك
الشهاده الماجستير يعني انا ممكن انجح
بعدد من هذه الدرامات واتواجد وممكن كثير
في بعض اللبنانيات اشتغلوا بس لبناني
وانعرفوا بس ما حينعرفوا على الصعيد
الكبير الا من خلال هوليود الشرق عن جد
مصر هوليود الشرق مش هيك مش هيك رايك سمر
بالضبط
كانت من اول ما بدات السينما اللي كانت
دايما فيها كل الجنسيات العربيه يعني احنا
لدرجه ان احنا يعني كتير من الجمهور
المصري ما يعرفوش ان في فنانين اصولهم
عربيه من كتر ما كنا كلنا حاجه واحده يعني
في هنقول نكته على الخبريه ههه فانا
بالمسلسل مع استاذ عادل امام كان المفروض
في جمله انه حبيب قلبي ما بعرف شو بس هيك
بلبنان يعني
فالجمهور المصري بالشارع اللي يا سلام
البنت دي فظيعه ده بتقول لبناني كده
[ضحك]
قلبه وقلب وبعشق البلد بس الناس في الشارع
عرفتني مصريه انا البنت بتاعت ايلات
انت بقيتي مصريه على الاصول يعني وحتى
الاجواء كلها مصريه يعني من اللبس والزينه
واحنا مش رح نطول عليكم لانه اذن من شوي
حنترككم على موعد الافطار وهاي الجلسه
الحلوه على النيل ويا بختكم انتم